hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a good husband the happy
family simulator where you get to be a
good loving husband to a good loving
wife and go home to your family and just
live out life to the best of every
possibility it's kind of like the sims
except not at all like the sims because
it's not at all like that
oh this looks lovely oh I'm so happy
oh god the controls are amazing on this
game this was recommended by you guys by
the way okay I'm glad my house is
situated on the end of the universe like
this oh boy maybe it's an analogy for
the fact that I can't escape this
horrible life that I live
oh I'm done now okay so I guess that's
it we said don't have to water it by
myself god it's just like the the left
and right key they just turn not on a
dime on a giant giant giant overly big
sir
oh this camera's good pay the bills plus
25 I'm getting so many points I'm
getting so many good husband points I
can't believe n where's my lovely wife
phone do I need to call my wife I need
to call something oh there she is
hello honey how are you did you just
look at my face and then become
overwhelmed with disgust I understand
that I'm looking at you and by looking
at you I mean I'm looking at the back of
my head but either way oh love you dear
watch TV don't make myself useful I'm so
annoying leave you alone oh but I want I
wanna watch TV with you I want to watch
whatever lovely programming you're
watching now apparently the points back
up I just paid the bill I just paid the
damn fell your wife you aah
but I love you anyway I'll pay it again
to rack up some points for attempting to
watch TV with my wife oh I'm such a good
husband oh I'm so get rid of these dumb
trophy Oh to you oh [ __ ] all my trophies
for all my accomplishments of good
husbandry and animal husbandry - I'm
very good at that so honey I'm watching
that [ __ ] oh are you watching this
[ __ ] you need to use your commas a
little bit better oh wait no yeah yeah
he's got less a lot better than that
let's eat up let's eat down what it's
just a fruitless task wait guess that's
the whole game here it's all just a
fruitless task it's not gonna go
anywhere
the story is stupid no one was here
thanks baby
you're so little huffing with your pink
face and mine is blue for some reason oh
this is so sad why am i laughing Oh
clean the dishes are cooked dinner
well they do they're basically the same
I'm making myself useful cuz I'm a good
husband and I love my wife they didn't
kill my wife
well I can't say I'm a good cook I think
Oh Oh on a platter my darling I brought
you food thanks did I lose points for
that did I really lose points
oh stop til Oh sharp at least I get 100
points out of it she's there is there a
point to this game like when people are
recommending to this to me was there
like a reason for me to do this like
what did you want me to see Oh
oh good I go slower when I have that ok
so there's an upstairs apparently I'm
gonna go upstairs next and enjoy the
rest of this lovely game that I play is
making me so happy about life there we
go ha ha ok upstairs we go
hello can I put the seat up and down can
I take a nice relaxing bath can I do
anything big blocky but sex Oh
she was looking right at him - those are
fake face that's horrible
oh god oh oh I understand now
I hope I didn't kill my wife I swear Oh
first-person mode good perfect for
exactly what I'm going to do why do I
need to do this couldn't I just leave I
mean I guess my house is situated on the
end of the universe so I don't suppose I
could actually go anywhere but why is
this necessary this isn't what a good
husband would do what do you think
you're doing with that nothing nothing
at all put that away why am I losing
points for it this is so sad I don't
want to do it I'm gonna call the cops
you're apparently not moving what do I
have to what come on you got a gun in
your face and you're gonna say that oh
that's so oh can I just shoot her in the
leg no it's just aimed head height the
entire day god damn is there nothing I
could do
oh I can't even leave the room now oh ho
that's so okay so I go in there can I
put the toilet seat up and down a little
more no well let me escape won't let me
go oh you son of a [ __ ] I don't want to
do this
it's like calm time I suck the [ __ ]
beg you be playing I'm so sad I didn't
kill my wife
wait yes you did Oh guys so sad why
would you make me do that well there you
have it
you made me feel emotions you've just
left why did he get trapped in that room
oh why recently he only outcome that was
possible just divorced her at any time
and he would live lovely happy life free
of that even if he got half of his stuff
it would have been better than living
with that I mean she's just cheated on
him three months ago I like staring him
directly in the face like okay what
marriage is that oh my goodness
oh this is gonna make everyone sad
anyway happy fun thoughts for the rest
of the day don't shoot people don't hurt
people be good people don't hurt people
and shooting them and don't hurt people
that you care about or married to by
doing things that hurt them emotionally
it's just as bad so everyone you in
respect with this game please go out and
give someone a compliment today like no
matter who it is stranger best friend
family member someone you hate give them
a nice compliment and hopefully you can
spread a little bit of joy and make
today just a little bit better after I
for like it just really fat came so you
go I thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for suggesting this
game to me if you want to check out the
other horrible emotion invoking games
you can check out the description or the
annotations over there
thank you everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]
electrocute the man of games why would I
want to do is a crushing sense of
loneliness and it reminds me I'm just
sitting in a room alone doing a let's
play of a game talking to a camera